My first job on Wall Street was a summer internship at Credit Suisse First Boston.
And I was 22 and I was like a total mess.
I ended up getting sober from drugs and alcohol...
...and calling this counselor who started working with me on the spiritual path.
I started on Wall Street and my first bonus was 40,000 dollars.
And I was so excited.
I mean, can you imagine like for the first time getting this check...
...that all of a sudden, it means I'm not living paycheck to paycheck...
...and I just felt like okay for the first time in my life.
I had this super cool life...
...and I was kind of making more and more money and rising up the ranks,...
...but at the same time, five years into my career on Wall Street,...
...I'd come in and I'd sit at my desk and I would just be consumed with envy and jealousy.
And I would look at these guys around me that made so much more money than I did.
And even though all of a sudden I was making 500,000 dollars or 1,000,000 dollars that year,...
...I'd look at the guys that were making 2 million or 10 million.
And I'd just like burn with envy.
So, that's when I started to get a sense that, "Maybe this is like an addiction."
So, what's the point of this?
You know, you're spending your whole life being really smart...
...and making these really crucial decisions,...
...but at the end of the day, all you're doing is sort of making more money with money.
When I was on Wall Street, the most important thing in the world for me...
...was whether or not I was gonna make one or two million dollars that year.
And the longer I've spent away from Wall Street,...
...the more I've come to see how sort of distorted that was.
And I'm not saying that money is bad.
Money is great and it's always better to have more money than less money.
If you're like me and you have this hole in your heart,...
...this sort of brokenness inside,...
...and are trying to fix it by proving to the world that you or I is valuable,...
...it just doesn't work.